hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled causes and consequences
of immune gene diversity in plants
this webinar is part of the microbiology
virtual week
virtual event and i'm susie valdez of
lab roots and i will be your moderator
for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker
detliff vival an executive director at
max
planck institute for developmental
biology for a complete
biography on all of our speakers please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
deadlift welcome you may now begin your
presentation
um thank you susie thank you everybody
at
lab roots for having me really
really happy uh to be here in the
virtual microbiology week to
tell you what we are doing um susie
already
introduced what i'll talk about causes
and consequences of immune gene
diversity in plants
a more catchy title would have been
paranoid plants and you'll
you know learn in a few minutes uh uh
what what they are these paranoid plants
so we'll gonna be looking at microbial
diversity but really through the lens
of the plant and how the plant responds
to
microbes so before um we get to the
actual science i'd like to acknowledge
the people who actually did the work
are currently in the lab christina
baragan
annetta habring leili derrick lundberg
and manuela neumann and then
a number of people who have left the lab
on youngjae who's a professor at
national university of singapore
dan koenig at uc riverside and
taya karasov who just moved to a
professor position
at the university of utah and i'll show
photos of them as we move along so
i'm a geneticist by training and
genetics
is what i love i've even written an
essay published in the journal genetics
on
why i love genetics and
one of the reasons is this cool genetic
phenomenon
which is called epistasis so without
epistasis
genetics is just boring so you have
two parents with genotype a
b they have some phenotype plotted here
on that
y-axis and if you cross them you get
a hybrid of genotype a b
and if there would be no interactions
between genes if
everything would be strictly additive
then
these hybrids would be strictly
intermediate as i said
that's really boring now
fortunately that's not always the case
so one type of epistasis one that is
often being discussed in developmental
genetics
for example is when one parent is
dominant or largely dominant that is the
hybrid
even though it has the genotype a b
phenotypically
it just looks like the b parent and the
effect of the a parent
is completely masked
that's that's already cool but it gets
much cooler so and it's really you know
what what i like to call
epistasis as evolutionary
magic and plant breeders know this as
hybrid vigor or positive
heterosis and particularly well known
from corn and you see
three corn cobs there on the top right
so again we have our parents a and b
that are different
in some phenotype for example size of
ears
and then we get the hybrid of genotype a
b
and it exceeds the best parent
so exactly as you see in this
in this picture now i said there are
these
two different types of epistasis and
developmental genetics is
one genetic background a mass the other
genetic background
here in this example you get something
that is more than additive
and a short excursion
into history here so why
is that that we have these different
definitions of epistasis
well actually batson was thinking about
this first type of
apostasis in his book ben mendel's
principles of heredity and
he said when one factor basically masks
what the other factor is doing
let's call that epistasis one over the
other
now this other definition where
it's anything that's more than additive
and actually the hybrid
looks uh uh beyond what you've seen in
either parent
that comes from fisher's um definition
and fisher said you know apostasis
is uh the deviation or epistasi he said
is the deviation from the addition of
superimposed
effects and why do i bring this up well
there are these two very different
definitions
and or rather different definitions and
has bothered me for a long time
why they are there and it really comes
from these
two founders of uh the disciplines of
statistical genetics on quantitative
genetics baits
and and and fisher and you may ask
today um fisher was quite a few
years after bateson so why you know did
he get away with uh
publishing a very different definition
of epistasis
and um i'm sorry i was a little bit too
fast
um as you um see down there he he
published this
uh in 1918 and
this work was actually uh
reviewed by uh no other than
punnett pune whom you know of um punnett
square and it should have popped uh
popped up here his name
and uh punnett actually pointed out that
bateson
had come up with this previous
definition but you know fischer just
blew it off and that's why today
we have this confusing situation all
right so
back to the topic at hand now i was
discussing epistasis as evolutionary
magic but there's also epistasis as
evolutionary disaster if you will
if you have two genotypes um
a and b and then the hybrid a b is
much inferior to either parent
and that's what's could be called
negative heterosis
or hybrid weakness so how did we
actually get into hybrid weakness
well this was a chance observation by
a student jana lemper 15 years ago or so
she was looking at two lines of
arabidopsis diana from this village here
where you see the map not very far from
tubing and where
i am these two lines called uk1 and uk3
and you can see that they were flowering
at
different times and we thought okay
that's interesting
at the time we were developmental
biologists in the name of my
institute let's try to figure out what
is the genetic reason for these
differences
and flowering so jana crossed both of
these um together
and came back a few weeks with this
really strange observation said i did
the cross but something completely
unexpected
happened so i get these uh progeny plans
the f1 plans but
they look really weird they are they
they don't grow well they're really slow
and so on
and it was it was really fortunate that
she paid attention to this and didn't
just
toss the plans but thought about this
came to me
and then we discussed it for a long time
and we couldn't quite figure out what
was going on but
we were fortunate that kirsten bumble
he's from uh who is now a professor
at eth in in zurich joined us at the
time
and kirsten did many more crosses of
different
aeroducts as planned so i just realized
i hadn't actually introduced
the organism that we work with this is
no corn any longer this is actually the
plant everydapc is um
sayana as hopefully many of you will
have
recognized uh workhorse of plant
genetics
so christian saw that they have many
similar cases so
this is really a thing if you um if you
will
so as i said by staring at the plans we
couldn't quite figure
out what was going on but we had a
number of hybrids that were all
much smaller than their parents and here
you see three cases on top is always one
parent on the bottom is the other parent
and in between
is the offspring when you cross these
two parents and you see they are much
smaller although
um it varies a bit how what they exactly
look like
so we looked at the gene expression
programs in these
hybrid plans and this is a very long
time ago so this was still
with microarrays not with rna sequencing
and really much to our surprise
even though these plants had
quite different phenotype they were very
similar gene expression program
and the only gene ontology or g category
go categories that were over represented
in these genes that were over or
underexpressed
were genes that related to immune
response so in other words what we found
was
that these genes had greatly activated
immune response and so one of the
outcomes of a high activity of immunity
in plants
is cell death so the way you can think
about this
the plant gets attacked by pathogens and
then often you have local
cell deaths so locally where the
pathogen comes in
the plant kills off its own cells
to stop the pathogen in its track
and indeed when we look for dead cells
this is what we saw so again these uh
three crosses with the hybrids in the
center
and then on top you see leaves that were
stained for dead cells you can in all
the leaves you can
recognize the veins which are composed
of that cells but then only in the
hybrids do you see
in between the veins also
um these these dead cells it's it's most
apparent actually in the example they
are in the
center so um
what we concluded that we are dealing
with cases of autoimmunity because we
had not challenged these plants in any
way
with microbes or other pathogens and we
also observe
these defects when we grew the plants in
sterile conditions
notobiotic plants if you will
all right so this is then our
interpretation here's the plant
or here the plants um there are microbes
everywhere and plants
know if you will that dangerous microbes
are
everywhere just like you know we are
programmed to
be prepared for onslaught of pathogenic
microbes and
and other predators so plants know that
they have an immune system
and they are prepared to mountain immune
response when
pathogens come along but here it's more
like
um maybe
we're just imagining they are micro so
these
plants imagine that they are being
attacked by microbes
even though there aren't any microbes
around so they are sort of
you know indicated with that uh with
that cartoon on
on on the top left there they are really
paranoid plants so
plants that are um
[Music]
paranoid in the sense that they
mount this immune response without an
attacker
so how could one explain this simple
hypothesis
um we have one genome and one parent we
have
another genome in the other parent now
we bring these two genomes together
and the obvious hypothesis is that
something in
one genome or from one genome recognizes
something from the
other genome as foreign or pathogen
derived so remember we're bringing two
plant genomes together
but apparently one plant genome makes
something
that causes something else from the
other plant genome
to activate the immune system that's at
least how we thought about it
when we started out with this and
so we call this phenomenon hybrid
necrosis because there is this extensive
cell death this necrosis here and
it's actually common form of hybrid
weakness as we later on
realized when we back it went back to
the literature we saw that there were
hundreds of cases described by breeders
and naturalists although apparently not
in in maize and these are two examples
from wheat again you see
two parental plants they're crossed
together and the f1 hybrids
they are really you know puny and then
they are quite
quite sick and when you read the paper
describing these it's quite clear
that they suffer from immunity
interestingly enough even though we
found
all these papers in the literature
nobody had really said
that these plants suffered from
autoimmunity so there was something like
a mental block for the people
who had observed this um they were just
not
prepared to think about plants
having and mounting an immune response
in the absence of
pathogens so that was really our
discovery that we
realized that what was was going on here
was uh autoimmunity
all right so we then
wanted of course to know what are the
responsible genes for this
and went on to map
the genes in this cross and we found
that the genetics of hybrid necrosis
is simple and that actually agrees with
what was described
in the literature for these many many
other cases
that had been observed before whenever
anybody had
bothered to look what the genetics
looked like they had found the genetics
was simple was
you know one two genes or so involved
and
what you see on the top is a
quantitative trait locus or qtl map
you see very uh two very nice
peaks on chromosome three and five
for dm1 and dm2 and that's the name that
we gave these
genes dangerous mix dm
and it's the dm2
version from uk1 that contributes to it
and then on chromosome 5 it's the dm1
version of the other parent uk
3 that contributes to it and again this
is work that we did with the dangle lab
back then and the bottom is just a
different way to look at this
to show that we have two loci on
chromosomes three and five
that apostatically interact and jointly
give this phenotype that i just
described okay so we could map this and
we proceeded to find map and identify
the causal gene
and we were delighted because we found
in the
dm1 encodes an nlr immune receptor
nlr stands for nucleotide binding site
loose and rich repeat
protein very similar to
nr immune receptors in animals
and they on the left you see the first
structure which was published about a
year ago by gigi chai and john mendoza
group really a a fantastic advance
for for the field and you see that forms
this
pentameric um oligomer the the the
specific
nlr that they um looked at okay
so um
what is going on here in this specific
region
of the uh um of the genome
so we're looking at pieces of genome
from three different strains so in the
center is
the reference strain of arudopsastayana
called columbia zero
or abbreviated call zero and in this
portion of the genome
you have two nlr genes next to each
other
and they are very similar so apparently
the result of a recent
gene duplication now if we now go to the
bottom
we see in the uk-1 strain which has if
you will the good allele so the allele
that does not
cause any problems we already see it
looks quite different so there are three
genes but actually none of these genes
are
intact uh compared to the reference
allele
and then on top is uk3 so it has
actually only one
has one intact copy and one partial copy
and uh having a complete copy of this
nlr
gene here would suggest in indeed you
know this this would be consistent with
this idea
that this is caused by this immune
receptor gene and then we showed this
genetically
that indeed dm1 from uk3 was
sufficient and necessary for hybrid
necrosis in uk1 so for example we can
introduce an extra copy into the uk one
strain which has the bad allele at the
other locus
or we can knock out the dm1
gene in uk3 and then we can cross these
plans to uk1 and nothing happens
now on top what you also see there they
have 20
amino acid differences between the nr
gene in uk3 and the genes in call 0 or
uk1 so this is of course huge so
normally within a species
the number of amino acid differences
that you have in a
single open reading frames single genes
is on the order of a percent or much
less and here it's
20 percent of immunoassets are different
so
they these genes actually almost look
like they
uh are completely different genes rather
than alleles of the same gene but this
is very typical
for these nlr immune receptors and we'll
come back to that
later okay so we were psyched um that
gm1 encodes an nli immune receptor so
that's sort of what we expected
um but we were rather puzzled when we
cloned dm2 and it turns out dm2
also encodes an nlr in your moon
receptor
and you see here the situation at this
locus is even
crazier than at the dm1 locus so
in color these are all nlr genes you see
this is a very large
cluster with up to a dozen or so
um different nlr genes and the color
indicates sort of which genes are most
related to each other
and if you just eyeball it so the second
row
is again the reference genome and then
the bottom are three
different uh strains of arabidopsis
diana which carry these causal alleles
um it's it's very clear that you can't
make sense out of this
by saying okay so this is the
evolutionary pass
so it's unclear how you went from the
reference uh situation and called zero
to the situation in either uk one or
blah one
or uh the ler strain and this is again
very typical for these nlr genes these
nlr clusters
that is this amazing mind-boggling
diversity
and they essentially look like regions
of genome from different species
rather than from members of the same
species
okay so a little a little aside how do
these proteins
work so i had already mentioned that
they can form these
oligomeric structures and we'll come
back to that later as well
but this is sort of a simplified version
how these proteins work
so they have these loose and rich
repeats they have these nucleotide
binding sites that's
nb and then they have an n-terminal
portion
that is either a third domain and
t-i-i-r or c-c domain that's sort of the
business end
of the molecule so normally um they
are in the adp bound state and they are
in an
off state so they do not signal and then
they can either directly or indirectly
uh detect the presence of a pathogen
protein called the pastor
effector that was a little bit too fast
let's go see well i can go back there
so can detect the presence of a pathogen
effector
adp gets kicked out and then you go
through an intermediate state to the on
state where adp is exchanged with
atp and you see that the business and
the tur
or cc domain now is available for doing
other things and so specifically
it can form this oligomer and
the an oligomer of the turret and cc
domain
can can do things we still don't quite
understand what exactly they
they do so how do we then interpret the
the fact that we found that two
different immune receptors
um could cause problems
well what we
later found out that these receptors
can form oligomeric complexes
and apparently if you mix the wrong
wrong receptors
then they are too often in the on state
so these are enzymes that go back and
forth between often on state and they
should only be in the on state when a
pastor and protein comes along
but when you mix the wrong receptors you
get complexes that spontaneously go
into the on state and then signal
so so we figured out that
you know at least sometimes immune
receptors are involved and
we have this one case where on both
sides it was immune receptors
but when on young jay joined the lab
about 10 years ago onyeng said well i
really want to know this
this much more systematically what what
i really you know
throughout the species how common is and
what are the genes behind it so
we came we became our adoptive breeder
when young
did over 6000 crosses with
80 different strains those were the
first strains that we had whole genome
sequence
at the uh uh in the in the late
to 2000s they came from eight different
geographic regions and what you can see
here that
yeah about two percent of random crosses
between accessions of arabidopsis diana
result in hybrid necrosis um
different classes so this magenta is the
worst class and blue is a relatively
mild class not
too surprising mild class is actually
relatively common
and we think this is sort of a tip of
the iceberg situation
indicated was this iceberg there on the
top uh right
that there are even more cases where we
don't see
obvious uh phenotypes with cell deaths
and so on and so forth
but where we might have uh already a
sub-threshold activation of the
immune system in in in the hybrids
so by that time we had all these genome
sequences so it had become relatively
straightforward to pinpoint the causal
genes
and it really confirmed what we had
already learned from this
single uk-1 uk3 case that very
often nlr genes were involved so what
you're seeing here are the five
chromosomes of areodopsistryana
and color is the density of nlr genes
and when you look at where
who the cause of genes map you see that
almost all of them
map to nlr genes with some exception
exceptions they are in in gray and you
have um
all kinds of genetic configurations so
you have configurations for example at
the
rpp45 a cluster there on chromosome 4
about in the middle
where two different alleles of the same
gene can actually interact
to give problems then you have
situations such as dm2 that is the
the gene on chromosome 3 they're in the
middle
where we have many different alleles
each of which can
interact with another locus somewhere
else in the genome
and then my favorite case is really rpp7
that's
over there on the left and side on
on chromosome one where we have several
alleles
and each of this allele interacts with
another allele at the rpw8 hr locus
which
you see on chromosome 3 in the middle
and so
this is a case that christina baragan
looked at
in more details so this should go to the
next slide there yes
so christina baragan looked at this in
more details as i already mentioned we
have
three different alleles at the rpp7
locus three different alleles at this
rpw8 locus
that specifically interact so merc 0
gives problems when crossed to kc 10
but not when crossed to the phase 0
strain and so on and so forth
so christina then looked at these
genes in more detail and what she found
was that this rpw8 hr locus
even though it is not uh in
an nr uh it doesn't encode nr proteins
encodes proteins that are somewhat
related to some nr proteins
but even though they are not nr genes we
have
nlr like sequence diversity so again
what you're seeing here are not
different species
it's the same region of the genome from
a number of different strains of
abdomina
and you have this mind-boggling
diversity with expansions and
contractions
and many different ways so sometimes
certain genes are missing and sometimes
one gene or a few gene
get duplicated many many times as you
see there
on the um on the bottom
and laylee when
he came to the lab he took this on to
try to figure out
how this all works at the molecular or
biochemical level with the
help of aneta harboring and he could
show
really very very nicely that in this
case this non-nr
rpw8 or hr protein acted as a
ligand that induces oligomerization of
the
rpp7 nlr receptor so
um you're looking at a blue native page
experiment
so where you separate proteins
without denaturing them and on top you
see
which proteins were in these plants from
which we extracted the
the proteins you see if we have
the bad combination if you will rpp7b
from a certain strain lyric and combined
with
hr4 from another specific strain called
phase zero
you see that we formed this very large
uh
oligomeric complex of about a mega
dalton but if we have the bad rpp 7b
but the good hr 4 version from columbia
0 from call 0
that's on the left nothing happens and
similarly if we have the bad
hr4 phase zero but uh the
closely related rpp7 a from laric not
the b
but the a version again very little if
anything
happens there so how do we interpret
this what we
observe there well we are
hypothesizing that hr4 phase zero mimics
in effect and modified hr4 called zero
so so what does that mean
so our hypothesis is that uh based on
similarity of these proteins to proteins
from
uh fungi and mammals and also what we
have
seen directly by looking at these
proteins we and others
that these hf4 proteins that they form
oligomeric complexes that insert into
the
plasma membrane of the plant cell and
then either contribute there to
cell deaths or allow the exchange of
molecules
between the inside and the outside of
the
cell and this is important for defense
now for a pathogen
to be pathogenic it has to suppress the
defense so typically how pathogens do
this is
that they deliver their own proteins
called as effectors
into plant cells and then these effector
proteins often modify
the plant proteins that are involved in
immunity so we hypothesize these hr 4
proteins are
modified by some unknown effector and
then they can no longer assemble
and insert into the membrane and
now you don't have then you suppress
immunity because hr4 can't do its job
anymore
and this is why plants involve the
second layer of defense where they use
these
nlr receptors to detect proteins that
were
modified by pathogen effector proteins
so we hypothesized that rpp 7b
normally detects hr4 proteins that were
modified
by a pathogen effector and so what
happens in the
hybrid necrosis or hybrid immunity case
is
that the hr4 phase 0 protein
looks to this rpp 7b receptor
like a pathogen effector hf4 called zero
so you don't need the epaston effector
anymore in order for hf4 and rpp7
to interact you then have this
oligomeric complex and activated
immunity and lots of other work
with uh similar proteins have taught us
that
very likely there is a wide range of
uh probably mostly direct interactions
between
nlr receptors and
these uh potentially promiscuous
interactions between
nl proteins that they apparently limit
possible immune receptor combinations in
a single genotype what do i mean with
this well
um different plants and i mean different
members of the same plant
species are resistant to different
spectra of pathogens and that's because
each of them
has a different collection of immune
receptors encoded in their genome and so
you can ask yourself well if say
you know 10 resistance is good why
does a plant not have 20 or 30 or 40 or
50 different resistances
and the answer is apparently the more of
these immune receptors you put into your
genome
or you have encoded in your genome the
higher the chances
that some of these receptors interact
even in the absence of pathogens so that
naturally limits
how many immune receptors a single
genotype can
uh can encode and that's supported by
work uh from others who've also found
these uh plenty of evidence for nlr
networks all right so what have we
learned um epistatic interactions in the
plant immune system are common
many translate into direct protein
protein interactions
um perhaps the most important lesson is
that too much diversity at immune loci
can backfire because you start to harm
yourself as a plant
and for the aficionados of this area
the study of natural autoimmunity has
actually revealed new aspects of the
plant immune system because
until our work nobody had seen this
higher order oligomeric complex directly
in vivo even though
it was known that it could be
reconstituted in vitro
now um these noi immune receptor genes
are indeed very polymorphic this from a
study that we
published last year of annalina banda
bayer and
felix bam where we had enriched for nlr
sequences from 64 different individuals
of arabidopsis
biosequence these nlr sequences
assembled about 13 000 of them
and then asked how they are distributed
and what you're seeing here is
that the majority of these nlr genes are
present actually on very few
individuals and only very few nlr genes
are present
in most or are all uh individuals so
again there is really
amazing diversity and i had already
shown you this amazing structural
diversity
so where does this really come from this
nr diversity so this
looks a little bit strange here but
doesn't uh
make a difference this is something that
damien kermig
investigated when he was in the lab a
few years ago
and he really stumbled across this sort
of by chance he had looked at
three different species of capsella it's
a relative of abu dhabi styliana
capsella rubella
grandiflora and orientalis and he had
focused on the capsular rubella and
grandiflora initially because
capsella rubella is a species that arose
from
grandiflora relatively recently 200 000
to 30 000 years ago
and when you look at the genetic
diversity
in capsular rubella you see that it is
relatively non-diverse
compared to grandiflora so these
branches here are much much shorter
in rubella compared to grandiflora and
all and
the whole rubella diversity firmly roots
within grandiflora and there's lots of
other
evidence to say yeah rubella is a
species that arose
out of um grandiflora so
fine um so he looked at diversity in
rubella he took uh looked at diversity
in
in grandiflora and we saw at the whole
genome level that rubella is much less
diverse
but the surprise was that the diversity
within rubella is very
unevenly distributed so here we're
looking at one chromosome chromosome 2
and on the right hand side boxed in red
you see that there's a region of the
genome where
when you look at many rubella
individuals almost all of them
look very very similar so the value for
diversity is close to zero
and it all and another value that tells
us
how different this rubella is from the
average grandiflora
you see that value is quite high so
rubella as a whole is very different
from
the uh for from the average of the grand
floridas
but then there are these other regions
of the uh genome where
diversity within rubella is very very
high
and the diversity that you see in
rubella you also see in grandiflora so
this
blue value fst is very low so
if you look at that region of the genome
you wouldn't know is it from
rubella or is it from grandiflora
whereas this other region that i
highlighted before
if you would have a look at rubella you
would have a look at grandiflora you
would know
what species it comes from so this
affects about two percent of the total
genomes and
dan found there are 20 regions where
these effects are
most strong and most of them
overlap either with nlr immunoreceptor
genes or
other immune genes and many of these
have actually known functions
in paradoxes they aren't so so this is
so let's go back here so this is kind of
cool so what we find is
that the rubella species could lose most
of its diversity but
somehow it had to maintain the diversity
at these immune receptor genes
but this is of course an n equals one so
we don't know
quite what that knows so wanted to know
whether this is supported by the
analysis of a much more diverse species
and so fortunately we had access to this
other species called capsella orientalis
which is from central asia from a very
different place
than rubella and grandiflora and when
you look at this
green tree you see that the branches are
very very short which already
tells you that these genomes are very
very similar and indeed
when we compared i think it was 16
different individuals
overall there were only 70 000 snaps and
that's very very little if you take two
random grandiflora individuals you
compare the genomes you have about a
million differences
but here in orientalist even with 16
different individuals
we only come up with a total of 70 000
variants 70 000 snaps remarkably
a really high proportion of these about
15 or so
are also found in grandiflora or rubella
or found even
in grandiflora and rubella so even
though the species
split three million years ago from
grandiflora and rubella
even though almost all of its diversity
was lost
the little diversity that is still there
is also found in grandiflora
and rubella and you won't be surprised
what are these genes
of course again they are immune receptor
genes and this just shows that
you know where we have diversity in in
in orientalism maps very perfectly
on to the regions where we have also
diversity in
rubella that is shared with the third
species grandiflora
and um when we uh look at uh
one of these regions in in in more more
detail this is
a little bit complex uh this graph here
but if we
go um along this region of the genome
and
first let's look at the top there um
when we make phylogenetic
trees that initially we have blue goes
with blue so all the rubella individuals
are similar to each other
red goes with red so the orientalist
individuals are
similar to each other but then as we
move to the right all of a sudden we get
these very
different trees where we have two very
different groups of alleles
and that one group of alleles has both
blue and red members
and the other group of alleles have blue
and red members so in other
words we have two groups of alleles in
both
species and the difference between the
two
alleles is much much larger than the
difference
between species at the same allele and
the same is actually
shown in this graph at the bottom this
just shows along this region of the
genome
the difference between different alleles
in either orientalism rubella
or between the same allele in the two
species and you see the difference
between the same allele in the two
species that's relatively uniform
it's only about three percent that's
what we'd expect after about
three million years but between
different alleles it goes up to
15 and that uh will remind you of what i
told you earlier
with this uh difference of up to 20
amino acids between different nl
alleles so again we have these very very
different alleles and we find them
but we find them in both species
so why is it that uh
um often the same loci uh that we
maintain diversity at the same loser and
even the same alleles this seems really
odd
so in green is what you see here where
these orientalist individuals come from
many thousands of miles away from where
the rubella and the grandiflora and blue
and orange
individuals come for from so certainly
in central asia
you have very different pathogen
pressures so it's really a little bit
confusing
that you have the same allele so so so
of course we would want to know what are
the pathogens that we respond to
now that's easier said than done because
there aren't books where you can look up
what
plant pastries you have where but we
need to understand if we want to
understand
you know what drives the immune system
diversification
we need to understand what the pathogens
look like in the wild and so
this is something that very recently we
have
relatively recently we have gotten into
um so where we have actually looked
at what are the microbes that we find in
natural aveda sociena plants and we
found
for example here around around tubing
and here
that there is a locally common
pseudomonas
toxon which we call ogu5 which
drives bacterial load so meaning that
when we find plants that have a lot of
bacteria inside them
then it's almost always this otu5
pseudomonas so there is a round tubing
in there as a single pathogen
that apparently exerts most of the uh
bacterial pathogen pressure
on uh plants now what you would think
this should now make it easy to
understand the evolution of
what happens in the plant because one of
these one of these bacteria are so
dominant
unfortunately we also need to know what
drives the
evolution of the pseudomonas verde flava
otu5 group of strains
and so derek lundberg he has looked at
bacteria of plants
that grow next to our arabidopsis plants
and you just here have some eye candy of
these
what these plants look like and what you
found was that unfortunately
this strain is really widespread that
you find it not on every plant but you
find it on many
different brassy cases so that's
indicated in
in this graph here so um
while we know that viridia flower exerts
substantial
pathogen pressure on our doxes we do not
know whether abdopsis is also an
important
a selective pressure on this otu5
so to understand this more broadly we
started this project called pathodopsis
pathogens on arrowdopsis
where we've been sampling aerodopsis and
its pathogens from
wild places all over
europe and this is really driven by this
idea
that nothing in evolutionary biology
makes sense except in the light of
ecology
wonderful quote from rosemary and peter
grant in their uh book on how and why
species
multiply and well so i talked about
arabidopsis
and most people would think it is just a
lab plant but what you see here it's a
real plant that grows outdoors
from the uh beaches of uh the baltic sea
to uh mountainous regions with lots of
slow
even in spring and lastly i want to
acknowledge
the max planck society for the extremely
generous funding of my science
and i'll be happy to take questions now
thank you
thank you detliff for your informative
presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far
left of your screen so let's take a look
we already have a couple questions
that have come in what a great
presentation
deadlift why are nlr
genes so diverse do they mutate quickly
yes so that's an excellent question
susie so
that's sort of the gut response that one
would have if you see a lot of diversity
at genes and
in a species so you would think yeah so
these must be genes that you know turn
over very quickly that mutate all the
time
but um we actually do not know how
quickly they
um evolve because they are
so diverse it has been really really
difficult to attract them
and there is actually this
counter-intuitive finding which i try to
bring across
with the uh especially with the capsella
work
that we have alleles that are very very
different but they are just very very
different because they are really
really old so normally when a new
species gets founded
you get rid of most alleles and you
start with a single allele and then this
allele
diversifies but in this case there are
many alleles that survive the speciation
process
and so in in in those you know who care
about
a mammalian immunity it's very similar
to what uh
you find at the mhc locus and primates
so if you
would take the mhc locus and you look at
a chimp
you look at a human and you would just
have that piece of dna
you wouldn't know whether you looked at
the genome of a chimp
or a human because these alleles are
older than when we
split from gems
wow thank you so much our next question
and again to our audience members
thanks for sending in these great
questions
our audience member wants to know i
often hear that mike
and plants or animals or humans are
engaged in this
arms race is that a good metaphor
yes yes and no i would say that they are
engaged in arms race so what an
arms race implies that you always have
to invent
something new and so then it would make
sense that you know both the pathogens
have to mutate quickly
and the plants have to mutate quickly
and certainly sometimes that seems to
happen
but often it's more like a long-term
stalemate and a situation that
evolutionary biologists like to call
a red queen situation or there's a red
queen hypothesis
and that comes from you know through the
looking glass
where the red queen says it takes all
the running one can do to just stay in
place
so you have to change but it's not that
you have to invent something completely
new
but you have to recycle these alleles
which are around so this is why you
maintain these very different alleles
so sometimes the one allele is
good then a pathogen comes in that
recognizes it
so now the other plants which already
have this other allele they go to the
top and then it goes
goes back and forth like this rather
than you know
directional selection thank you so much
we have time for one more question what
is the difference
between microbial uh community structure
and the microbial diversity is
understanding the distinction
between the two important yeah so i
think that
the the diversity is is the way i
understand it the diversity
is more a descriptor so it's just you
know so what species are there
um how many difference is there within
the species and so on
the structure is is more what is the
relative
uh proportion and then how does it
change over time so for example you
might have two species that support each
other and that always co-occur
so then that's part of the structure
because when you look at different
in different plans then these two
species would always be there
together so for me a structure implies
much more of a functional aspect than
just the descriptive effect
which which you have in diversity
this has been great thank you so much
for this presentation
oh actually we have one more that just
popped in can i go ahead and give that
one to you as well
sure yeah um this audience member wants
to know
do plants have a sort of epigenetic
genic similar to human epigenetics um
that we're learning about oh yeah
so i assume i i assume this question was
a little bit inspired
because in in many ways the microbiome
can often be thought of
as similar to epigenetics where
something that can be inherited from
parent to child but it's not encoded in
the dna so if you pass on the same
microbes
in epigenetics it's modification of the
dna
which are passed on and that's actually
something that my lab has worked on
quite a bit
how different epigenetic states can be
passed on
where the dna doesn't change but you
still have different
functional states and what we found for
example that you can
when you regenerate plants you can
actually induce
distinct epigenetic states where then
although the dna hasn't changed the
plans look different and you propagate
these plans
this is passed on to the to the parents
wonderful thank you and actually we have
another one what are the two
to three biggest environmental factors
that strongly form plant epigenetics
um so the the things that
we often look at are abiotic stresses so
that seems
relatively clear so abiotic stresses
such as drought
that's for for for our
wild plants and also for crop plants
drought extreme drought is one of the
greatest
challenges currently all over the world
and
getting worse with with global change
so drought is a really big factor
certainly stresses such as salt another
important abiotic factor
and then temperature what is
less clear i would i would say is
how much epigenetic changes are that are
induced by pathogens so
that's of course you know so many many
people have been looking for this and
that this would connect to
what i talked about so basically if a
plant has seen a microbe could it pass
on that information to the next
generation you know be prepared for
this particular micro
della thank you so much would you like
to provide our audience with some
closing remarks before we go today
yeah so this was uh really fun to
tell you about my my work i hope this
was a little bit
different from what you've heard
otherwise in this series which
was much more focused on the microbe
side but
it's really uh this this this
interplay between the microbes on the
one hand and the plant and its immune
system
uh on the other hand and uh if there's
one
uh takeaway um that you will hopefully
remember
is that there are limits to how the
immune system can
evolve
deadly feigl thank you again for your
time today and for your important
research
and before we go i'd like to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted on during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months until march 2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's time for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
be safe stay healthy
thank you